it's another slow start to the day for
Judy Avey for 30 years she's run a Sloth
Sanctuary in Costa Rica her team has
rescued and studied more than a thousand
of these animals raising them by hand
until they're healthy enough to be
released back into the wild
he says she's seen all kinds of injuries
but one thing is clear sloths are more
resilient than you think we've never
received a slot that has been sick that
has a disease or has an illness
we don't know if it's it's because if
they have this beneficial bacteria in
their hair we've received sloths that
have been burned by power lines and
their entire arm is just destroyed I
think maybe in the 30 years we've seen
five animals that have come in with an
infected injury
two and three-toed sloths live in the
canopies of Costa Rica's jungles there
are also the country's newest national
symbol
researcher Max chavaria was intrigued by
what Judy was seeing at the sanctuary
and took fur samples to analyze in his
lab
or foreign
if you look at the fur of a sloth you
see movement you see moths you see
different types of insects you see that
it is a place where we have a very broad
habitat and clearly when there is
coexistence of many types of organisms
there must also be a system that control
them
their theory was confirmed within the
sloth's fur they found what appear to be
antibiotic producing bacteria that fight
off pathogens and infection
why not think further that this molecule
could also be used for us in other
applications for example in medicine in
human health
specifically chavaria and his team want
to know if the sloth microbes could help
against antibiotic resistant superbugs
where standard treatments no longer work
they admit the answer to that question
is still a long way off but it's one
that's becoming increasingly important
the World Health Organization estimates
that by 2050 resistance to antibiotics
could be the cause of 10 million deaths
a year
and just like The Accidental discovery
of penicillin so many years ago
researchers here are hopeful Costa
Rica's sloths could hold a solution of
their own to a rising Global Health
threat
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera